he's writing the book as a cautionary
tale right and he says listen if I could
do it all over again I would still try
to get rich but I would have instead of
making you know hundreds of millions
maybe he makes 10 million or 20 million
rather cases but the most devastating
part is if I could do it all over again
I wouldn't have missed my kids growing
up and I would have had fun what is the
point of living in a 30 000 square foot
house owning a NBA team and you didn't
even have fun as he's trying to write
this book his co-author is interviewing
his wife and she says the most
devastating thing that if my family said
this about me I don't care if I have a
billion dollars I'm a failure and she
goes I miss him but it's not like he was
here when he was alive anyways when you
read a book like that you get to the end
it's like I'm not going out like that
I last night was with one of the first
Esports performance coaches so he is a
mental performance coach that is
employed by an Esports organization to
train their mental athletes as they call
them to maximize their performance and
the stuff that they the stuff that
they're doing with these kids is so cool
taking across all of the stuff that
we've seen from physical training now
and porting across into something which
is
actually I think the most mentally
taxing sport that that exists
yeah because you can move your avatar on
the screen significantly quicker than
you can move your body which means that
you're basically overclocking your brain
your brain was meant to move limited by
the pace of your body moving when it
comes to reaction times and what you're
doing now is you've managed to overclock
the physical world and you're now trying
to catch up mentally this guy was fact
of Thanksgiving dinner nerded out with
this guy for like two and a half hours
it was brilliant
that industry is very fascinating do you
know Blake Robbins by chance no okay
Blake Robbins he's a venture capitalist
he's over at uh Adventure Park now but
he actually incubated 40 thieves that
that uh Esports team and the brand and
everything else but his focus and why
he's been uh invited to take part in one
of maybe you know maybe the most
prestigious or one of the most
prestigious Venture Capital firms at a
relatively young age I think Blake's
like late 20s whatever case is he's
obsessed with the edge of the internet
and um he has this great line that has
actually taught me a lot that everything
is a game and his point is like if you
look at gaming as an industry it's
bigger than music movies and a bunch of
other things combined
um so I do think like it doesn't
surprise me that they they're at The
Cutting Edge of course they're going to
have some kind of performance coaches I
think everybody does like almost all the
top performers have somebody that they
actually want to bring in in fact I just
re-read
um so I've done I've probably done I
don't know 10 or 12.
by uh biography uh at episodes on Steve
Jobs
and then not only do I do I reread uh
like I read every single book I could
find about them and then I would reread
my favorite ones and then make episodes
every new time because the words on a
page don't change but like everything
that you've learned since the last time
you read it has changed right and then I
would map out in the book
um all of the people that he was
inspired by because none of these ideas
are new and I I wound up mapping it out
and I did like a little bonus episode
called Steve Jobs and his Heroes and it
just traces I've done 39 episodes on
Steve Jobs and the people he actually
mentions whether it's da Vinci Alexander
Graham Bell Edwin Lan the founders of HP
uh all these people that like influenced
the way he thinks about his work and
something Steve did on the second time
he went to Apple right uh the time where
he created all that value because if you
think about it he's kicked out of apple
spends 13 years in the wilderness right
from like age 30 to 43 comes back and
essentially the way I think about is
like apples in terminal decline it's
almost bankrupt right it's running out
of money they pay 500 million dollars
for next and you could think about it
it's like they paid half half a billion
dollars to rehire Steve Jobs and they
got the deal of a [ __ ] Lifetime right
fast forward you know now or 20 years
later it's the most valuable company in
the world worth like 2.4 trillion
dollars but what he realized was it was
very helpful and I actually heard a
bunch of episodes you referenced me and
you both share uh an admiration for
Charlie Munger he's like one of my
personal Heroes and he says this he's
like the role that he plays with Buffy
it's like it's very useful to have
somebody else to organize your thoughts
with professionally right that's the
role that he plays with Buffett so what
Steve did is he hired this guy
and he didn't had no official role
inside of Apple so he'd fly down he
lived in Seattle he fly down to
Cupertino on Sunday night I think he
would spend from Monday Tuesday
Wednesday all he would do is Shadow
Steve
he could not say he had no Authority
inside of the company he's just he's
with Steve all the time and when they
have a minute they'd have lunch together
or they pull him to the side they have
one-on-one conversations and it's that
same thing it's like you might not call
it a coach but it's somebody that is not
a part of your company right doesn't
technically work for you but it's very
hopeful to to bounce ideas off of and to
like organize your thoughts so whether
you call it a coach performance coach
you know a friend Confidant I think that
you see that idea over and over and over
again there's that story about Marcus
Aurelius as he was walking through the
streets of Rome he would pay another guy
as all of the the small folk were
throwing flowers at him and saying
you're amazing you're this sort of God
Emperor we're so glad that you're here
and the empire was flourishing and
there's this guy walking behind him just
whispering in his ear you are only a man
you are only a man so you could imagine
if you were able to bring somebody back
down to earth like that but also have
that as a confidant someone that you can
bounce ideas off just how powerful that
would be I've noticed since moving from
um having a business partner in my last
company to now doing the podcast where
it's me at the top of the tree doing it
on my own I do miss being able to speak
to someone and just go dude I've got
this I've got this idea am I being a
[ __ ] like is this is this a good
idea and you go yeah of course it isn't
yeah I knew it was thank you I knew it
was I knew it was a good idea I just
needed someone to externalize like to
just
blow off all of that extra kind of
mental uh energy and just cut cut
through the noise
um one of the guys that I've heard you
talk about a good bit and I keep on
hearing about him from people that I
respect a lot but I don't know much
about him is Paul Graham yeah what do I
need to know about Paul Graham so
programs I just spent the last like
three weeks inside of his mind because
he's got you could read all of his
essays online for free at paulgram.com
and he's been writing for you know over
two decades in fact uh I was talking to
a friend of mine um my friend Patrick
who runs the invest like the best
podcast
um and we were talking about that
because you know every single as far as
like influential writing for technology
startup Founders it's like Paul Graham's
essays I'm talking the last like you
know 15 20 years it's like programs
essays uh Jeff bezos's uh shareholder
letters which are absolutely fantastic
I've read you know multiple times and
then Peter thiel's book zero to one and
so I read I spent the last three weeks I
read I did three separate episodes on
programs essays and I was like you know
what I'm gonna re-read zero to one I
think this is the third time I read it
but in the view of how does this relate
to what Paul Graham like how he thinks
um and the thing that I think relates to
what you and I do is he has this idea in
fact the collection of his essays is you
can buy the book it's called hackers and
Painters and he's like at the very top
levels it's you there's no like painting
by numbers right a lot of the best
things
um are I hate to use this word art
because that's not the way I think about
when I make a podcast I think of like
it's a craft and it's like I'm actually
making something but it's it's not
science and it's not art there is like a
a form of taste to it right
um and so he's like the best painters of
that way the best computer software like
uh the best programmers are that way
because he's a programmer
um he says like the best musicians are
that way I think podcasts are the exact
same thing where there's this great I
just I watched your uh your appearance
of Joe Rogan Experience which is
fantastic by the way you did a good job
thank you and it was fascinating because
um
Spotify before they try to do that deal
with Rogan this came out the person that
I forgot her name but the the woman that
was in charge of this is like well is
there a way for us to say like can we
replace Joe there's nobody has an
audience his size right uh but can we
replace him with like maybe five that
are similar and like we'll kind of
package it up and it like replaces them
and so they ran this test and like no we
have to back up the truck and like
there's only one Joe Rogan and so if you
would even ask Joe like why is your
podcast so popular right or like he's
he's gonna have a hard way describing
because he's like I'm just being me I'm
following my natural interest and one
thing that I always say in this relates
to program too is like the most
interesting people or the most
interested right so like I like I'm
obsessed my four interests have to be
entrepreneurship reading history and
podcasts right and some people are
always like hey what are your favorite
podcasts and they're surprised by one of
my favorite podcasts is this podcast
called meat eater and this is a guy
named Steve rinella right it is an
outdoor hunting podcast I don't hunt I
have nothing against it like maybe I
will one day right but the point was
it's like I've read all of Steve's books
he is deeply interested he has dedicated
his entire life to the outdoors and
conservation and his way of life and his
his level of detail that he's able to
talk about and the passion is just
infectious so it's like I'm not even
into what you're into but I just find
the fact that you're so into it
interesting so now I'm interested dude
my my housemate Zach is the most
infectious person when it comes to
energy so you know the uh is it
Motocross what's the thing that Colin
McRae used to do rallycross
um where these guys are flying down dirt
tracks at 100 miles an hour and they've
got the co-pilot with them and there's
people that go out to take photos
and then they'll usually have a little
bit of a crew with them and they'll be
these special spots along the track
presumably ones that are maybe a little
bit more safe not at the corner of bends
on the outside of them and stuff like
that and these guys will have gone it'll
be the middle of the night it'll be
pissing cold it'll be raining and
they'll stand there to see
and these dudes just like and they'll
look at each other they'll lose their
[ __ ] yeah and Zach likes to watch that
to gas him up before a training session
like he just gets so infected by other
people loving their [ __ ] and uh this guy
the Esports guy last night same thing
[ __ ] who loves his loves his [ __ ]
couldn't tell me anything about like
valorent or [ __ ] rocket League or
League of Legends or any of this stuff
but he loves his craft and that gassed
me up to hear him be so passionate gas
me up so that ties into what is the main
theme across multiple decades because
like Paul Graham starts out as a
computer programmer right starts this
company called vow in the late 1990s
like two months or two years later sells
it to Yahoo for like 50 million dollars
right then he's like well now I got
money for the first of my life what
should I do he's like I should learn how
to invest it starts this thing called y
combinator y commentator you know it's
the most prestigious startup school
version of like if there was a college
entrepreneurship which is impossible to
ever have one it would look a lot more
like why comment or anything else that
invest invest in you know thousands of
companies winds up becoming a
billionaire off of this and his entire
theme relates to this is like what do
you like who are you as a person what
are you naturally interested in Jeff
Bezos is a great line where he's like we
don't pick our passions they pick us
right so Paul starts like who you are as
important like what are you into he's
like I'm really into painting I'm really
into computers I like reading he has
like this deep historical knowledge of
you know English History and everything
else and says like you start with who
you are then like what do you actually
want to do like how do you find an essay
that changed my life that I recommend
everybody reads is how to do what you
love
um and it's like first of all find out
who you are then find out like what you
actually love to do find a way to do
what you love but make sure that it's
valuable to other people right and if
and if you're making something people
won't wear this a podcast a software
program a service whatever it is and you
you really love to do it you'll be
really good at it and if you're really
good at it you'll do it for a long
period of time and if you're really good
at something you do for a long period of
time that's a you have a high likelihood
of getting wealthy and so that is the
main theme that is why I think it
doesn't matter what whether you're
working inside a company whether you're
an entrepreneur whether you're a
podcaster it doesn't matter it's like I
would read I'd find programs essays and
read the ones I find the ones that you
like and then read them over and over
again because they think they're
extremely powerful his Clarity of
thought and the clarity of writing is
second to none there was a internal
apple meeting with Tim Cook and someone
asked him about whether it should feel
like hard work when you do something
that you love and one of my friends was
at this internal meeting and he told me
what Tim said in response he said you'll
have to work harder than you ever have
before in your life but the tools will
feel light in your hands
yes so [ __ ] cool think about if you
ask anybody
who has the most drive or who's like the
hardest work you've ever seen and the
one name will pop up over and over again
this is Michael Jordan right and I read
uh not only did I read Michael's Auto
autobiography driven from within but I
read this like 700 Page biography which
changed my [ __ ] life and it's called
uh Michael Jordan uh the life I think by
Roland Lazenby and what was so
fascinating is Michael even says he's
like everybody talks about how my work
ethic and how hard I how hard a worker I
was they didn't understand it was all
play to me like me I've heard you speak
enough where me and you also share love
her the the philosophy and the thinking
of Duval ravacon uh in fact our mutual
friend the way the way we connect is
Eric jardinson and I at Eric's book The
Almanac and of all it's like I give that
away
I I think I may have bought that more
copies of that as like somebody to give
away than almost any other book I could
think of and especially for somebody
that doesn't know what to do they're
like man I'm struggling I don't know
like what direction I take in life is
like read it read the almanac in the
fall
and so Naval has this idea it's like
fine work that feels like play that's
also in Paul Graham's essays and you see
it again in Michael Jordan so it's like
wait a minute like maybe Naval was
influenced by Paul Graham but Michael
Jordan shirt as hell wasn't and yet he
arrived at that same conclusion he's
just like I'm the laziest and you would
see this in his childhood they're like
man we couldn't get this guy to clean
the kitchen he couldn't do his homework
but when it came to playing sports
baseball first and then basketball you
couldn't he would never get off the
field and then he'd realize oh where am
I weak then he'd go find he's like oh I
need to lift weights or oh I need to
work on my endurance oh I need to find a
coach that can actually teach me and
he's just absolute sponge because it
felt like playtime and that's the whole
thing was like it's very difficult to
get really world class go back to the
Joe Rogan it's like what are his what
are the things that he's obsessed with
right he's obsessed with and they all
interconnect if you think about it's
like he was doing UFC commentary for
free when it was nothing you know uh I
wish somebody would write a biography of
Dana White because that's a fascinating
story that needs to be told it's like
you you you you buy this uh company so
that's it's almost going to business for
two million dollars you blow it up make
it a worldwide sport sell it to ESPN for
what four billion or something like that
um and then you ask them were you ever
gonna quit he's just like uh I love what
I do I travel the world I State the best
restaurants I eat it I stay at the best
hotels eat the best restaurants and
watch the best fights in the world he's
like I'm not even working like why like
there is nothing to quit like this is
there's nothing I'd rather do than this
um and so I think that that's like you
picked up on like that's the key it's
like if you really want to be great at
something you have to do it for a long
time and if you don't really love to do
it you're not going to do it for a long
time there was this story I heard about
Steffi Graf German tennis player like
Savant when she was still playing and as
a kid they did an assessment of
motivation and of technical skill and
some people were coming in high on one
and low on the other and so on and so
forth Steffi Graf came back as 10 out of
10 on both so what you have with this
person is not only someone who has the
raw talent to be able to beat you but
they're going to continue outworking you
and today it's not even going to feel
like work but it feels trite to talk
about this now right like no one can
beat you with being you it's very
difficult to beat someone that's having
fun like you know how many times do we
need to drill this home but perhaps one
more time like it's an important lesson
I have something interesting to say
about that because this is something
that I discovered because so like
fundamentally right um I should back up
like
for the podcast so far I've read you
know close to 300 biographies of
History's Greatest entrepreneurs right
uh to even get on Founders podcast you
have to be so good at your job somebody
wrote a [ __ ] book about it like
that's an insanely High bar maybe the
highest bar that you could possibly have
right and so every where everybody
thinks it's like these people must know
something we don't right it's like must
be super complicated or something it's
like no no it's like they identify the
very the basics right they find they
identify a handful of things that are
important to them and they repeat them
for decade after [ __ ] decade Jeff
Bezos is a great example of this right
uh you think about it like Jeff Bezos
mastered uh what it means to run a high
growth technology company on the
internet before there were any playbooks
right like he essentially wrote the
[ __ ] Playbook when he started in 97
how many people started uh an interior
company 97 they're still going today
like he wins by endurance let me
actually show you something real quick
because this is going to tie into it
because I forget but like this is this
is uh my lock screen right that is a
cover of
Ernest Shackleton this is fantastic book
written by Alfred Lansing called
endurance right and the reason I have
Earnest [ __ ] Shackleton looking
at me every time I look through my phone
is because he had a family motto his
family motto was by endurance we conquer
and so something I've noticed from
sitting in a [ __ ] room by myself for
four years seven days a week reading
every single day of my [ __ ] life I
read a biography entrepreneur for hours
that's the first thing I do after I wake
up I wake up work out and then I read
forever for hours as long as I do that
for the rest of my life I'll get
whatever I want out of my life because
then I package up what I learned and I
put it on a podcast for other people too
to benefit from right and so what I
notice about these people is this like
jet go back to Jeff business example
it's like
um he has they call him Jeffersons he
has it's not like he needs to remember
25 30 different things right it's a
handful of principles that are very
important that he's going to repeat over
and over and over again for decades so I
don't I understand people say oh let's
try to say Do What You Love or straight
to say that you have to have endurance a
trade it's like no these are the
fundamentals there's a great
conversation that happens between
so I've done
I don't know uh two podcasts on Michael
Jordan I've done like uh two or three on
uh Kobe Bryant I just read another 600
Page biography at Cobra brand right that
one of the last interviews Kobe did
right this is so [ __ ] important to
understand because you see this in every
single domain one of the last interviews
he did right before he died he talks
about that he was on the phone Michael
Jordan right
and he's like Michael he's like he's
watching uh unfortunately the daughter
that passed away with him in the um in
the helicopter crash he's like man I
don't really like what their coaches are
teaching me he's like they're teaching
these 12 year old kids like all this
fancy [ __ ] he's like you know spin moves
and all sort of stuff and he's like I'm
pretty sure I didn't learn this when I
was you know when I was playing so I was
like let me call Michael and see what he
says right so he calls he's calling on
Michael he's like he's like hey man
um you know she explains the story I
think they're they're teaching these
kids way too much fancy stuff they're
not focusing on just mastering the
fundamentals on a deep [ __ ] level and
the way to do that is repetition over
and over and over again for a long time
and he's like Michael what do you think
he goes he goes he's like Michael what
were you learning uh what were you doing
in uh basketball uh when you were 12 and
Michael goes dude I was playing baseball
and then Kobe says I'm pretty sure he's
being interviewed by Alex Rodriguez the
famous baseball player he goes think
about that and his point being is like
the greatest basketball the player to
ever live hadn't even picked up a
[ __ ] ball yet your 12 year old does
not need to know these spin moves and
all those other fancy [ __ ] focus on the
fundamentals and they do that for on a
deep fundamental level for decade after
decade after decade I want to go back to
this idea that you and I both share an
admiration and love for Charlie Munger
he has this great thing
we're saying hey Master the big ideas on
all these domains so he has this thing
he says like they carry most of the
freight I think is the term he uh he uh
uses he inspired me to like how can I
what am I learning from you know doing
this a rather unusual work that I do
it's like my version is like time
carries most of the weight I just heard
or I saw a tweet that you said where
it's like you've been doing this podcast
500 and some [ __ ] episodes right
first of all you know as as I do and we
don't have to get into the business by
kissing because I'll never shut up about
it because I'm clearly obsessed but like
everybody's like oh it's too late to
start a podcast there's millions of them
and then you actually look at the data
and this is like how many of them are
producing uh how many of them basically
how many of them are still producing to
this day have done more than 10 episodes
and haven't [ __ ] quit and it's like a
couple hundred thousand and so my whole
point is like imagine being able to go
back on the internet when there's only a
couple hundred thousand blogs or a
couple hundred thousand websites and
you're telling me it's too [ __ ] late
what are you talking about that's insane
because everybody quits at everything
and the reason I was so interested is
like not only do I respect Eric
jorgens's opinion a lot find them
extremely sharp and articular person but
he's like Chris is the real deal but I
can see that you're the real deal
because it's like this dude has done
something 500 [ __ ] times how many
people have done that and then you had
said something he's like I've been
grinding away trying to get really good
in my craft and I want to talk about
this conversation you had with uh
somebody also admire George Mack which I
didn't know his name was George McGill
until you said something I haven't
fallen on Twitter for years
um and we've been dming stuff because he
listens to Founders too but another
sharp guy but um uh but the the point it
was making is this like you made the
points like I've been grinding ground
and grinding and yet
this is something I also uh talk about
on the podcast it's like you have to
stay in the game long enough to get to
get lucky because there's an opportunity
right that's gonna happen year five six
seven is you cannot comprehend in your
one two three this is very similar to
what Jocko said in your conversation
he's like oh five year plan guess what
the way Jocko talks about is the fact
that he's optimizes for flexibility uh
an optionality is how all of the best
entrepreneurs that have ever lived in
the same way you think that's the case
they have this sort of emergent uh
outcome in life
there is I don't know about an emergent
outcome but they definitely optimize for
optionality so there's this guy
um I don't want to lose the thread real
quick let me I'll tell you about Henry
Singleton in a minute but how I like
what you said it's like that one
opportunity that you had to grind away
after years and years and you never
probably predicted to happen but once
that happens I think you said you had
more downloads and like you know a week
or whatever then all the years combined
yeah that's a perfect [ __ ] example of
stay in the game long enough to get
lucky there's a million [ __ ] examples
like that in the history of
Entrepreneurship you just have to go and
read old books to find them so let me go
back to this optionality person so what
I'll do is when I find somebody that's
very interesting to me right
um I what you'll be shocked is like how
almost done other ideas are unique to
them right so like I'm obsessed with
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger uh I
read all the Warren Buffett shareholder
letters uh I read all the biographies I
could find about both Warren buff and
Charlie Munger and when they say hey go
study this person and they do because
they're both obsessive readers they
they're both biography nuts uh Charlie
Munger has probably read more
biographies than me but I'll think I'll
catch them because I got 60 years you
know he's got six years later but they
what's fascinating is like you find all
these great people buried in history and
we can talk about why don't don't worry
about your legacy and all the other
stuff because it's a lot of us fake you
imagine how so few people actually go
back and we could talk about uh some
examples in history entrepreneurship but
what's fascinating is like Charlie
Motors the one of the wisest people
alive right and he's like hey the
smartest person I ever met with this guy
named Henry Singleton I'm like what the
[ __ ] and he's like his returns were uh
he's like utterly ridiculous so you know
how Charlie talks then Warren Buffett's
like you guys need to go back and read
about Henry Singleton he built a
conglomerate very similar to Berkshire
but like 20 years earlier right and
they're like Warren says hey it's a
crime that American Business Schools
don't study this guy so wait a minute so
let's pause right there you have how
many people on the planet have studied
more entrepreneurs and more businesses
than Warren Buffett a tiny he might you
know have studied more than anybody else
and this and he's telling you yo this is
the guy go [ __ ] pay attention to this
guy and then he says some [ __ ] like hey
if you add up the top 100 business
school graduates uh NBA graduates ever
uh their record and then compile the
record together it would still be
inferior to Henry Singleton so then you
go and you read there's not a lot of
material on second thing but I read
everything I could find and I didn't uh
a podcast on this book called The
Outsiders which is one of the very few
books that profiles what what made
Singleton so it uh so interesting and I
absolutely flip my [ __ ] because all the
ideas that I thought were buffets a lot
of them came from Singleton and to me
that's inspiring because it's like I
don't I can I can Thrive and be wildly
successful and I don't need one single
original idea of my own I just need to
master what uh what some of the best
people in history have already figured
out for me and then you could pick up
the book and in you know 10 15 20 hours
you get the distillation of a career and
lessons they had to figure out over 40
50 years that's absolutely insane so
Henry Singleton's like listen he has got
this famous quote uh he's like you know
everybody has a lot of especially 1960s
70s there was this theory that you need
like a Five-Year Plan you need a 10-year
plan you need to have all these
projections he's like the world is so
much more complex than that he's like
and we have so little control over
outside things so he's like I like to
steer the boat every day he's like my
only plan you know what his [ __ ] plan
was same plan as Jocko I'm gonna show up
every day go to work and I'm going to
steer the boat a little bit like in One
Direction and I'll go and I'll try
something and if it works I'll do what
Josh said I'll do more of it oh it
didn't work I'll stop doing that that's
fine and I love what he made the point
he made on your episode which was
fantastic uh which was hey if you asked
me six years ago what my five year plan
was he's like I didn't have a podcast
and then all the stuff he's like hey
podcast blows up he sells all these
books now they're returning into movies
he's got his manufacturing company he's
yesterday I came back just for this by
the way uh I was out of town for
Thanksgiving and I was like sorry I'm
leaving I have to go record with Chris
tomorrow and so all the way I did I had
to do this like four and a half hour
drive yesterday and I'm just slamming
Jocko goes because all the Starbucks are
closed on Thanksgiving Day
so those are legit man I was really
really impressed with them the only
things are open or the wall was and
Jocko has made a huge influence on my
life and I'm not an engineering person
I'm a stressor person like all day long
but I was like [ __ ] monster you've never
done anything for me it's like Jocko's
giving me hundreds of hours of fantastic
content his I don't read a lot of books
that are not biographies but his book
extreme ownership is to me the best
single best book on leadership that I've
ever read and I was like I'm loading up
on Jacob so just slamming them down as I
went by but yeah so what I saw with
Jocko I saw uh even uh Warren Buffett
and Charlie Munger saying the same thing
he's like we don't have a master plan
he's like we're gonna the opportunity's
gonna come in a lot of them we can't
predict we're gonna say do we want to
pursue this opportunity or not and why I
think that's reassuring to people is
that I struggled I was one of those
people that didn't have a very good plan
if you say what you want written on your
obituary where would you like to see
yourself in 25 years that's something
I've always struggled with and yet
because I came from a
productivity efficiency background at
least when I first started the show that
was one of the things I was obsessed
with I always felt like I know a little
bit of a fraud because I didn't have
that as it was laid out and I think that
you're right
understanding principles and allowing
things to be directed from there each
day one step at a time permits you to
have enough optionality to take
advantage of good opportunities when
they come to you but it is important to
have the principles I think without an
understanding of what it is that I need
to be doing consistency enthusiasm
discipline ensuring that I fall I
continue doing the good stuff whatever
the things are that facilitate your
performance those need to continue but
you don't necessarily need to have the
plan all the way out so when it comes to
looking at all of the guys and girls
that you've studied from history what
are the most common threads in terms of
personality types the ways that they
show up that all of the high performers
have had
so it's not it's funny because I've been
approached by a couple Publishers and
like hey why don't you write a book on
like the top 10 traits I'm like [ __ ] you
like it if you think about it like the
world is much more complex than that and
what we're doing right like a podcast as
a business it's a form of
Entrepreneurship like entrepreneurship
done at the highest levels yields the
greatest Financial results in the world
right there's no formula possible so the
way I look at it is uh same way where
like
um when I just re-read this the 600 Page
biography of Kobe Bryant like you would
go to his house at like 17 years old and
like you'd open the closet and be VHS
tapes of Michael Jordan of all these
Magic Johnson all these other people
his girlfriend is high school girlfriend
in that book
is gives its interview and she's like
what was it like to date Kobe Bryant
high school she's like well a lot of
Saturday nights at his house watching
tapes of Michael Jordan right so the way
I think about is like reading
biographies of History's Greatest
entrepreneurs is one all of History's
Greatest entrepreneurs did this the more
biographies you read right the more you
realize people live life so remarkable
somebody wrote a book about them all red
biographies like it is you can read
other things and you should read other
things but I don't think uh you can have
a complete human life without reading
biographies consistently you know uh the
way I always say is like if I I like
people like how should I use Founders
podcast because now there's like 400
over 400 hours and like I add to it
constantly it's like listen to an
episode find one book that you like read
one biography uh a month right this is
the minimum like requirement in my
opinion read one biography a month and
then listen to two episodes a week that
means after a year you would have
downloaded key insights and lessons from
100 different history schedulers every
year and then you gotta go deeper
because my episodes are only an hour
maybe 90 minutes it's like these books
take me for everyone an hour of audio
that I create I'm reading at least 20
hours like this is not a [ __ ] game to
me like I take this dead dead seriously
just like History's Greatest
entrepreneurs do so one thing I I would
say like one traits all like that a lot
of them have
is the importance of practice
um and so there's this Maxim that I
repeat over and over again that the
public Praises people for what they
practice in private the public raises
people for what they practice in private
I repeat that to me over and over again
and I mentioned earlier it's like how
why this guy say that reading a
biography of Michael Jordan changed his
life like what the hell is it like that
sounds silly to me like how could that
possibly be true and there's this one
story in there that I thought was so
[ __ ] remarkable because it talks
about the difference even at the highest
level so to get into the NBA there's
like what 400 NBA players total right
out of millions of kids that want to do
it and I maybe have tempted to do it
then you get to like the All-Star and
maybe you have you know 24. now the 400
down to 24. then in 1992 Jordan is
invited to play on the Dream Team in the
Olympics right he uh so now you have 12.
like that you can't get higher than
where he's at and he was thinking about
not doing it because he's like I've been
in the playoffs we're winning
championships he's winning every single
award he could possibly have he's at the
top of his game but he's like I'm going
to do it even though my body's beat up
because these are the best basketball
players in the world world right and I
want to see their practice habits
so the main the reason I say that
business that book changed my life is
because Jordan says he'd rather miss a
game than miss practice and so he gets
there and I get goosebumps I already
have Goosebumps because I know where the
stories can end and he gets there and he
sees the practice habits of the other
people in the Dream Team which they are
at the top of their class of their
profession but he's winning more
championships to them he's had his
accolades are just better than he's he's
the very top and he said something that
[ __ ] changed my life and he said that
they were deceiving themselves about
what the game required
and so that from there how I applied to
my work is like I'm gonna work on the
podcast seven days a week I'm going to
read uh biographies for uh for hours and
hours every morning when I'm done I
store all of my highlights uh and my
notes in this app called read wise I
have over 20 000 highlights and notes
from all the books I read and so what's
my second half of my day is [ __ ]
practice which is now re-reading it's
not good enough that I read a book a
year and a half ago that's not [ __ ]
good enough dude you're asking people to
spend an hour and a half of their time
with you in their ear so I have to make
sure that I am not only like I have to
live this stuff every single day I was
just invited to speak at a company
it's the private investment companies 93
years old the CEO of the company's
assistant Founders they have 250 billion
dollars for asset Center management and
the CEO me and him get on a zoom
beforehand uh they're having a company
off site with like 40 to 60 other
partners and he's like hey do we want an
outline or whatever the case is I go I'm
perpetually prepared I promise you I
will show up you can ask me whatever the
[ __ ] you want and I will know it
backwards and forwards and he's like why
and I explain why like I go I got this
over here for Michael Jordan and then
I'm not [ __ ] playing basketball over
here I'm making podcasts and reading
books but this the principle is the same
thing so let me tie this to one of
histories guys I'm sure it's Sam Walton
right if you think about how [ __ ]
crazy Sam Walton's story is that dude
started out in retail when he was like
in his early 20s right doesn't hit it
for like 25 years he was like 44 when he
founded Walmart right but he wasn't like
lollygag and he was like working at
different forms of retail he was just
having to go through that
experimentation the time carries most
weight thing right and so
he had this idea for Walmart he was
under fine financing his idea was hey uh
all the big retailers in the big cities
I'm gonna see if I can build these
stores that are far out in Rural America
right in towns of eight thousand ten
thousand fifteen thousand people right
I'm gonna pick cheap real estate
and I'm only going to continue price his
the thesis behind Walmart which if you
think about this the thesis was proved
correct as a result this have his thesis
being proven correct he generated one of
the largest fortunes the world has ever
seen his [ __ ] kids are still like if
you combine all of Walmart's kids like
uh like his descendants into he split it
up right but if it was like one person
they'd be the richest one if not the
richest person in the world right
um and that idea came from this is just
like well I think there's an opportunity
here that no one else is pursuing I have
a hypothesis let me test it he didn't
have money he goes to uh it was a this
thing called Ben Franklin stores which
is I might be getting the name of the
company wrong but it was essentially
like uh early franchise uh uh
headquarters that would franchise uh you
could buy retail franchises from them
and Sam was running one of those and he
pitched him on the deal and they're like
no no we don't want to do this that was
a Friday the next day the guy that told
him no goes to his local Kmart right
just to go shopping for whatever because
camera was a giant company and he hears
this voice he's like where the [ __ ] why
is that voice sound so familiar and it's
Sam Walton in there in Kmart with his
notebook which he would go Sam Walton
winning more his version of practice is
going in more retail stores than anybody
in history his kids talk about this he's
like it doesn't matter if we're in
Europe on vacation or anywhere any
vacation he's like we have to stop and
dad has to look at his stores every day
and so this guy had just turned him down
from one of the best opportunities which
turns into Walmart right so he [ __ ]
this up he just said no to the best
opportunity of his life sees Sam Walton
talking he's like okay how do you guys
do inventory okay why is this price this
way taking notes on a Saturday morning
that's his version of professional
practice and I saw somebody tweet about
this and um they're like imagine
competing with Sam Walton
and so the way I look at is like when
you're reading these biographies when
you're picking up these ideas you might
read a 400 page book or you might listen
to an hour and a half of my podcast to
pick out one or two ideas but those
ideas will stick with you forever and
then you can figure out how that applies
to your actual craft no one goes back to
the the Henry Singleton thing you
mentioned something I I wanted to jump
on where it's just like none of this
works if you don't work yourself in a
position to trust your own judgment as a
podcaster as an entrepreneur as an
investor who obviously these are the
people I make my podcast for primarily
right if you can't trust your own
judgment you were just saying you used
to have a business partner now you can
stop a heap it's what you'll also see
program talks about it's like Founders
talk they realize like other Founders
outside their company and Paul talks
about Necessities have a more of an
understanding of what they're going
through than their employees they can't
talk to their employees you also have uh
you and I have a gift where the easiest
way to make friends is to have a podcast
and then you listen to other people's
podcasts and now you're friends so like
you can talk to other people
um so those are just some of the ideas I
don't want to keep rambling but those
are just some of the ideas that appear
over and over again it's like the
importance of practice it's like the UN
unbelievable amount of dedication Jaco
said that uh on his podcast it's like
how many how I I heard him say something
on uh on Instagram live one time that
just made me laugh and you know he's
like look at his phone like reading the
questions and they're like how many
hours a week do you work he goes all of
them
it's that kind of thing because even if
they're not physically even if Sam
Walton's not physically working at his
business he's thinking about it that is
a form of work so that to me is
Obsession and obsession's not
necessarily a bad thing I would have
said one of the most common threads that
I've seen amongst High performers that
I've had in the show is Obsession You
could argue that that might be
compulsion uh by a different lens
do you think on average that the people
that you've studied from history were
happier than the average person
foreign
I think for a large percentage of them
happiness is besides the point
so this is that's not that question
though go ahead say the question is
on average do you think the people that
you studied from history were happier
than the average person
yes
this is the reason why even if they're
not over first of all I I I think you
were talking about this with Ryan
holiday which is like there is no
evolutionary point to be satisfied or to
be happy or like a Finish Line which I
think is a big mistake people always
like the hedonic treadmill it's like
people are always chasing after
something they get it and they don't
understand why they're not content so
it's like something I don't even worry
about anymore I just do what I want to
do every day and it's like I know I'm
always gonna a 10 or 20 of my life is
always going to be discontent somehow
you know as a driven person trying to
build a business like if you're content
you wouldn't do anything
um the reason I would say they might be
happier though is because a lot of
people think entrepreneurs are motivated
by money right and the money obviously
you know Jeff Bezos likes probably likes
his 200 billion dollars probably feels
really good right but I it's very clear
it's like they're motivated by control
and Independence they want control on
how they spend their time like business
building is World building right you're
able to build a world within your world
like in your in you're in our case right
we get to choose what we're going to do
when we wake up tomorrow you get to
choose who you speak to you get to
choose you have complete control over
people around you I have friends man
that even if they like their job they
hate some of their co-workers imagine
how unnatural that is from an
evolutionary perspective to spend half
of your waking time around people you
dislike or don't trust like so and to
that degree
I think because they have control and
they and samwell's cases like I had fun
you know one of my favorite quotes to
face is like most people don't enjoy
what they do like I really enjoyed it
and he wrote those words when he knew he
was dying cancer he had cancer all over
his body he knew he was dying and he's
looking back he's like no there's very
few things that would change the ending
of Phil Knight's uh founder of Nike his
his fantastic uh uh autobiography shoot
up what was crazy is that talks about
like the he has this dream right of he
has this goal he wants to deal with this
idea he wants to and then that book
every chapter is a year goes in in
chronological order and it ends with the
IPO of Nike and the crazy thing is this
guy overnight you know now he's worth
100 like 75 million dollars overnight
he's like this is amazing and then he
gets in the book he's like what do I
wish he goes oh my God
I wish I could do it again
like I wish I could go back and
literally redo this and now he's writing
those words as a 70 year old man he
knows like there is no time for that
that's not going to happen
um so yeah they may be happier than the
average person because they have more
autonomy and control over what they're
doing but these are not like I don't
even know if they're it's possible for
many of them to be quote-unquote happy
yeah so the common like the answer that
I would usually give when people ask
about high performers I had uh the
performance coach Michael Gervais who
was the guy that looked after Felix
baumgartner's psychological training for
him to jump from the edge of space had
him on the show and Felix was Felix was
struggling he had claustrophobia when he
got inside of this suit and there was
pressure Michael was brought into
coaching back out of that and I asked
Michael on average do you think that the
highest performers in the world are
happier or more miserable and his
opinion was that they're more miserable
and the reason that he gave was that a
lot of people that are high performers
are driven by a sense of insufficiency
that they're looking to to achieve
success in the outside world to fill a
void which is inside of them and that is
a Common Thread that I've seen with
people that I have spoken to that I've
worked with I've been around
um but I'm also perfectly open to
hearing from you someone that's been
exposed to
tens of thousands of hours of intimate
connection with some of the most smart
and successful people from history that
that might not be the case
um I do
think a lot about
whether people are sacrificing the thing
that they want in order to achieve the
thing which is supposed to get the thing
they want so for instance a lot of
people would consider that being
successful might make them happy and in
order to be successful they will
sacrifice happiness in the short term
and you go okay so you have an equation
here where if all that you do is remove
success from both sides I.E the strive
what you're left with is just happiness
and it's that story about the fisherman
the guy that goes down the fisherman and
he says you could build this up into a
business and then if you build a
business so big all that you would be
able to do would be official day and he
goes well that's what I do right now and
I do wonder how many people uh the
fishermen uh sorry are the businessmen
going to see the fishermen looking at
him and saying look there is there is a
void inside of me that can be filled by
success in the outside world and the
success will ultimately lead to
happiness the problem is that we look at
the modern world through such a narrow
band a narrow domain of competence you
saw this with uh who's the dude that did
fire Festival
oh the one that went to jail yeah him
yeah anyway yeah the only reason that
people don't like that guy and it's a
hilarious story is because the event
didn't succeed if he'd had different
weather if he'd had different beds if
he'd managed to get the the tents to
look even remotely okay he would have
been hailed as the greatest event
promoter of the last few decades right
it would have been the greatest thing
since Woodstock uh the only difference
is that he didn't get the outcome that
he expected well hang on a second
people aren't pointing the finger at him
because he didn't get the outcome when
it failed they're pointing at him for
these unethical business practices in
the lead up to it so what that suggests
is that the ends always justify the
means to people do you understand where
I'm coming from here I do yeah yeah
really really interesting that that I've
always think about that fire Festival
guy whose name I can't remember uh and I
would say one thing that is a little
different with the people that I study
is
a lot of people have like a means to an
end right so the the great uh benefit
like one of my favorite things like that
I get Jewish like profession is like so
I spend a lot of my time having
one-sided conversations with dead
entrepreneurs because I prefer to study
dead entrepreneurs I really don't focus
on entrepreneurs now but then that those
lessons attract people building modern
day Founders and so then I get to meet
them through the podcast and become
friends with them and the ones that are
the most successful are it's like
there's no means like for me it's like
podcasting is not a means to an end it
is the end the idea that like anybody in
the world like there's podcasting an
open protocol it essentially gives you
the ability to have an on-demand radio
show right about anything that you want
that anybody can access you can talk
about whatever you want and that anybody
can access all over the world like that
there's nothing better to me like this
is what I want to do for the rest of my
life and that idea it's like there I
always say it's like they're gonna have
to pry the microphone for my cold dead
hands you're out of your [ __ ] mind if
you think I'm gonna like I'm never gonna
stop doing this and what the people that
I admire the most is like they found
what they wanted to do Sam Walton I just
mentioned him right another one of my
entrepreneur Heroes Enzo Ferrari okay
everybody knows Ferrari the brand right
very few people know Enzo the actual
person now as an individual person don't
like him at all he was misogynistic uh
didn't really only didn't care any about
about anybody but himself and his son
and then his son winds up passing away
unfortunately right but I admire his
dedication he's one of his greatest
obsessives he worked on building his
business Ferrari he worked 12 days a
week seven days I'm not saying to do
this by the way I'm just saying like he
was completely obsessed he had he this
is what he chose to do for his life and
as a result anytime you see a brand that
has been around for a long time that
usually stands for high quality whether
it's like Ferrari uh the the founding
engineer of Rolls Royce same thing uh
Apple you always have you could uh Estee
Lauder Coco Chanel you treat Sam Walton
you trace it back to like this one
obsessive founder right
there was yeah that was doing things not
for it was it was like yes they wanted
to get wealthy and they all got wealthy
but they made weight they went decades
after they kept working decades after
they needed money and in case they're
like Coco Chanel worked she died when
she was like 87. she was working on her
last she was still working on her latest
like uh like her at least fashion show
her latest fashion line the year thing I
forgot what they call uh Estee Lauder
worked on her company until she died Sam
Walton worked on his company uh uh Steve
Jobs same thing uh is there something
sad about that though that a lot of
these people have got families you know
they could have spent more time with
their kids they could have spent more
time connecting with the people that
they care about this is my concern with
unfettered complete Blue Sky ambition
and ruthlessness that
it I worry that it sets a trend for
people to believe that they need to go
searching outside of simple
life's
the simple lives in order to achieve
something that they that will fulfill
them when what it is that they're
looking for is right in front of them
like these people are unbelievably
ambitious they're very obsessed and what
that leads them to do is to engineer a
life which allows them to manifest that
Obsession and it may be one of the
greatest things for this particular
person to go and do Enzo Ferrari may
have been built to create cars probably
was but would his life in retrospect
have been better had he have spent more
time with his kids would his kids lives
have been better had he had spent more
time with his child I don't know if he
had kids my point being like looking at
it through the lens of how do I maximize
impact in the world whether it be Legacy
whether it be growth whether it be money
and it's often not just the cash as
you've said it's people continue after
that and you go okay well like what are
you doing this for you're doing this in
Pursuit Of The Pursuit itself cool great
is that all that there is to life
is a bigger question
so out of every single person that I've
ever studied they have all over
optimized their professional life at the
detriment of their personal life by far
there is one loan exception to this uh
it is episode 222 it's this guy named ed
Thorpe he is the title in the [ __ ]
podcast I made is my blueprint for life
right and
um he's got a fantastic autobiography I
recommend everybody read it it's called
a man for all markets
um the saint celeb wrote the forward and
you can actually read the forward for
free on nasim's website which is
fantastic and he outlines why at Dorp is
so unique now I have to preface this at
Dorp is a genius way smarter than I am
by far way smarter than I'll ever be I
can read 10 000 books I'll never be
smart as that guy right so what Ed
Thorpe realized is like enough one
enough was enough so
he identified a handful of things that
were really important to him he's like I
want to get wealthy right I want to have
work that's intellectually stimulating I
want to be a good father I want to be a
good husband and I want to take care of
my health and I want to have fun I want
to treat life like the adventure it is
there Tim ferriss's is fantastic he's
still alive right you can go Tim Ferriss
did a two-part interview with Ed Thorpe
recently you can listen to it but I
recommend seeing it on YouTube because
let's start with the health thing which
I know you're into as well right
um I sent that video to a ton of people
I was like tell me how old you think
that guy in that video is and
everybody's like I don't know 65 I was
like he's 90. he's 90. and so what the
genius in a Thorpe is like he had uh a
few simple systems and simple rules to
guide his entire life so he got into
physical fitness when he was a really
young man I think he was in college
right which is extremely rare you know
60 something 70 years ago and what he
realized he's like
um
every hour I spend in the working out is
one less day I'll spend in the hospital
at the end of my life
and he dedicated himself to eating
healthy to taking care of uh of his
physical fitness and that's why he looks
to what he does he has actually a simple
system I I use in that book where he
gets up every morning obviously go to
bathroom and then he weighs himself and
the reason he does that is like it's
impossible for me to get like he has
tight food feedback loops for everything
he's just like you're gonna know when oh
it's like I lost a couple pounds I can
eat a little bit more today or oh I can
have that dessert or whatever it's like
a very simple feedback loop right he was
the inventor of the first quantitative
hedge fund okay uh he he would turn down
after he got independently wealthy and
it was all like uh something that he
found intellectually stimulating he had
unbelievable amounts of business
opportunities that come to the door and
his whole point is like even if I'm not
a billionaire I have hundreds of
millions of dollars I have this giant
house in Newport Beach California right
uh I have more money than I ever spend
why would I take time away from my
raising my sons uh spending time with my
wife uh having fun to go chase more
money something's wrong with me if I'm
doing that now if I happen to be uh
intellectually stimulated and I find
when I'm doing fun then I'll go do that
but it was like invest in oil tankers or
stuff like it's like I don't give a [ __ ]
about any of that
um he writes the book after his wife
dies of cancer and he talks always like
they were married for 50 years he's like
we spent he was I went home every day
and had lunch with my wife
he's like I worked 40 hours a week right
like he was not a compulsive workaholic
like a Steve Jobs or an Enzo Ferrari or
Jeff Bezos whatever the case is uh
he has great relationships with his sons
and he might have a daughter too and now
their kids where uh the founder of Ikea
right which is a fascinating story it's
called his name is ingvar camphrad he
started a kid when he's like 14 worked
on it he was like 87 right and he has a
line in his autobiography that [ __ ]
gives me the chills and this is
something I have two kids so I'm not
[ __ ] this up and he says uh he goes I
sacrificed the relationship with my
three sons I missed my three sons
growing up to build Ikea he's like don't
do this and he says a line he goes
childhood does not allow itself to be
reconquered that is a very common
mistake at the end of a lot of these
autobiographies and biographies it's
like I didn't I miss my kid's childhood
and you can't get that back and I [ __ ]
it [ __ ] that up right
um let me go back to that door and I
want to tell you about this guy Larry
Miller who wrote a book that I think
everybody should read it's called driven
an autobiography he was the richest
entrepreneur in Utah had a 30 000 square
foot looking uh 30 000 square foot house
overlooking Utah oh 93 different
companies he's writing the book as he's
dying and he's like my life is a
cautionary tale I didn't have fun I
didn't take care of my health he owned
the Utah Jazz go look up Larry Miller
you tell Jazz you see this obese man
sitting there on in one of those you
know Scooters or whatever like the that
people like little rascal yeah yeah like
so I'm gonna run down what he said too
because I think that that's valuable
even if people don't read the book let's
go back to Edward so then he he builds
this wonderful business right he meets
he has he lives with a Life Adventure he
winds up having dinner or uh he has
dinner they're both in their late 30s
with a 38 year old Warren Buffett right
he has dinner leaves the dinner they
want to be friends he leaves the dinner
turns to his wife and she he goes he's
gonna be the richest man in America one
day imagine being able like everybody
sees Warren Buffett now he's like this
old guy you know kind of chubby or
whatever eating [ __ ] Diet Coke and
McDonald's and stuff but like I always
like what I always do is like when I'm
studying somebody it's like I'll write
in a book it's like I want to know when
were they born and then as I work my way
through the book I look at the years
like how was that person what were they
thinking when they're 25. I'm in my late
30s like what were they what were they
doing when they were my age it's like we
we know the older version of them but
it's the younger version that built
their empire it's like what did that
person look like you can see what Warren
looked like when he was hit hair he had
glasses he dressed nicely he looked he
was like a sharp looking dude Charlie
Munger too
um he winds up being the first LP in uh
Citadel which is like one of the largest
funds in the world so my point is like
the guy had all these interesting uh he
built the world's first wearable
computer with Claude Shannon the father
of information Theory uh he uh edor
invented the card counting for blackjack
when you know ones and zeros and all
that stuff he he's the one that invented
that system writes a book in the 1960s
called beat the dealer sells millions of
copies this is my blueprint because it's
like yeah uh he was smart as hell he
made a lot of money but he was good he
was a good friend he was a good father
he was a good uh husband he took care of
his health and then he had fun you
wouldn't believe how many of these
people get to the end of your life and
it's like oh [ __ ] I didn't make any time
for fun and that's not how I think it
was like d Hawk who's the founder of
Visa he just passed away he's 90 I think
he's 93 years old A very wise person he
he turned his back he he uh he created a
Visa ran it for like 15 years and he's
like I don't want to do this anymore I
don't give a [ __ ] about money he would
wake up in the morning at five in the
morning right he was obsessed with
reading and writing like almost all
these people are and would write a
thousand words then he'd go out and
spend his day working the land
physically restoring the health of the
land he bought is this somewhere in the
Pacific Northwest so he said something
was fantastic he's like life is a
magical Odyssey to be experienced and
that's where
um I I don't I hope people realize like
when you read these books yes you
celebrate their accomplishments but the
reason that you need to read biographies
over business books is the human element
they get to the end and it'll tell you
don't do this what's the price that they
paid for that yes and so we go to Larry
Miller driven it's called driven an
autobiography by Larry Miller right
and this guy you know raised in [ __ ]
up situation his like when he get in a
fight with his mom and his mom didn't
know how to deal with him so she'd call
the cops she put her son in jail over
and over and over again then eventually
kicks him out right and so he's got no
education no skill set he is working in
as in a parts department of a car
dealership I think he's like 25 or maybe
30 years old and he just [ __ ] snaps
and he's like he had a fanatical desire
to achieve something and so then he just
starts working literally he's like if my
eyes are open I'm working right winds up
building over the next 30 Years doesn't
take care of himself as all uh he's they
said if you lived in Utah it'd be
impossible not to uh it was impossible
for an average Utah citizen to not spend
money one of his businesses so he owned
car dealerships and movie theaters and
the Utah Jazz and all this stuff right
didn't take care of his health didn't
know his kids didn't know his wife
uh get to the end of his life it's like
they're having to cut off his fingers
and his hands because his poor
circulation he's like obese really like
disgusting he's writing the book as a
cautionary tale right and he says listen
uh if I could do it all over again I
would have like stopped you know I I
would still try to get rich but I would
have you know maybe instead of making
you know hundreds of millions maybe
makes 10 million or 20 million where the
cases but the most devastating part is
like if I could do it all over again I
wouldn't have missed my my kids growing
up and I would have had fun and I'm like
what is the point of living in a 30 000
square foot house owning a [ __ ] NBA
team and you didn't even have fun then
the co-author he dies in the middle of
the book right
as he's trying to write this book his
co-author is interviewing his wife and
she says the most devastating thing that
if my family said about this me about me
I don't care if I have a billion dollars
I'm a [ __ ] failure and she goes I
miss him but it's not like he was here
when he was alive anyways
yeah so that's the power when you read a
book like that
um you get to the end he's like I'm not
going out like that you you either you
either have the ability let's go back to
our mutual love for for Charlie Munger
he says it's like he quote Cicero where
he's like a man that doesn't uh know
what took place before him is like goes
to life like a baby he's like if you
don't learn if you're if you are only
capable of learning through your own
experience which most of humans are
right it's very hard to learn through
the experience of other people it's like
you're gonna have a rough go at life you
will not have a great life what you will
probably be able to do would be learn
from the experience of other people that
are similar to your sort of age cohort
right like you're going to be around
most of your friends oh what did you do
oh I tried this thing with my business I
tried this new strategy for getting up
early in the morning I went to bed and
took this supplemented whatever
you don't get to do what people who have
got to the end of life and then
subjectively looked back and told you
this is what I would have done if in
retrospect I had lived a life worth
living
that's what you're optimizing for I
think there's a like a really really
strong case to be made that a good life
is one which in retrospect you're glad
that you lived there is some elements of
that that you miss off particularly the
hedonic stuff like you don't you don't
Embrace more hedonic pleasure
in retrospect and yet it does provide
you pleasure in the moment and that's a
little bit of a paradox or maybe a
dichotomy to be managed rather than a
paradox to be solved as homozy says
um but I think that especially if you're
the sort of person that's listening to
this show that listens to your show
you're going to be a bit more ruminative
you're going to do introspection you're
going to consider why am I here am I
adding value you need to optimize your
life to be one which in retrospect you
feel good about because not only will
that probably be things that are good
for you both in the moment and in future
but in the future it's like a gift that
you give yourself
you get to accumulate all of these
senses and feelings of Good Will and of
achievement in a holistic organic
ecological view it's wholesale right
it's everything it's not just this
narrow domain it's everything and that's
why it's so important to be able to have
a clear view of your life because I
wonder how many of these people maybe
some of them in the autobiographies are
still retreating to their own inner
Citadel which is I am happy that I
achieved this much I am happy that the
business did all of these things because
the temptation to open up the lid of
looking at what they maybe missed would
be so catastrophic especially as you're
perhaps a bit more frail at the end of
your life would destroy them
yeah I'm glad you brought that up
because one of my favorite ideas that
I've ever come across from any book and
it ties to the last part of your
sentence there was Jeff Bezos has this
thing called the regret minimization
framework which is like this nerdy way
to just to describe how can you get to
the end of your life with the least
amount of regrets possible right and so
he is in people like don't like they
know like I think it should be obvious
that Jeff's like super smart but he's
like genius level smart and so even way
before he started uh Amazon he's working
for this quantitative hedge fund in uh
New York City called de Shaw uh all
right yeah I think I can't remember if
the the guy the founders D Shaw the
actual fund is the uh D Shaw but anyways
it's run by this like quantitative
brilliant billionaire right Jeff is
making a ton of money he's got this
beautiful apartment in Manhattan and he
sees he's doing research for something
he sees that how fast the internet's
growing this is like the mid 19th it's
like 95 96 he's like oh my God he's like
things just don't grow this fast like
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
I want to take part of this and so he
can't get this idea out of his mind and
but all the external things is like no
Jeff you're already successful like like
if you can't leave now what about your
bonus and so he's like he goes to his
boss and they go for a long walk in um
in uh Central Park for like two or three
hours because his boss is trying to talk
him out of not quitting because in the
code name for what turns into Amazon
inside the hedge fund was called the
everything store like that is why the
biography by Brad Stone is called the
everything store and so Jeff Jeff's like
I I think I want to take a risk quit a
job while I can still do this and like
try to play a role in what I feel is
going to be a life like a an earth
changing time which is like the birth of
the internet which obviously has changed
our entire life the idea of me and you
even connecting could not have happened
without the internet right and so they
take a long walk he's like and his boss
like you know you stay here you're gonna
be rich you have this big bonus and he's
like I'm gonna go home and sleep on this
and he says he's like I struggle with
this decision until I figured out the
regret minimization framework he's like
27 or 28 year old Jeff Bezos is not
capable making the decision decision
this decision but 80 year old Jeff Bezos
is capable of making decisions so he
tried to view his life looking back and
he's like when you're on your deathbed
in your 80s or hopefully 90s or whatever
it is you're surrounded by the ones you
love you're going to be telling yourself
the story of your life and that person
is not gonna say they're not going to
give two shits that you that you quit
your job and you don't get your
quarterly bonus right but what they
would give a [ __ ] is like you had a
chance to play a role in the birth of
the internet right the way Jeff thinks
about internet is the way I think about
podcasting and I think like you also as
well it's like like we're at the very
beginning of the industry we have a role
to play here like this is amazing I
don't want to do anything else to focus
on this and so he goes once you make
once you look at that in that once I
looked at it in uh that framework he's
like decision is easy he's like jump try
to do it if you try and fail 80 year old
Jews Like good at least you got off your
ass you took a goddamn risk for once
your life good
try again but 80 year old he's like oh
you were comfortable like you were young
and smart and had he had no kids at the
time he wasn't even married yet I think
I think they eventually got married
because she uh she uh Mackenzie winds up
quitting and driving cross country with
him now how does that tie with what you
just said because that makes sense right
but then here what happens he he starts
up with his wife his wife knew him
before he was Jeff Bezos of Amazon she
helps him build the company that's why
she got this huge divorce settlement but
now you fast forward he's one of the
richest people in the world he's an
Empire Builder complete like Alpha nerd
right genius guy then he lets his family
fall apart now you and I will never know
like maybe he's like hey I don't care I
just want to sleep around I can get the
best women in the world or whatever
maybe that is what makes him happy I
don't know but I would I would love to
In Like These Quiet Moments does he
regret destroying his marriage or not
that would be a great question to ask
the price that people pay to achieve the
things that everybody else desires is a
question that endlessly fascinates me
I'm always thinking about it I'm always
thinking about it
let's go to the other end of the scale
so we've spoken there about some
examples of people that have tried to
create more holistic
um views of success who are some of the
most ruthless ambitious just Stone Cold
Killers that you've studied
foreign
Steve Jobs to me is the greatest
entrepreneur to ever do it and it like a
lot of this is subjective like but if
you had a Mount Rushmore of History
space entrepreneurs he's got to be he's
like Elite you can't have four other
people on there that's not him right and
the sad part about the fact that he was
um
I I just like the like the quality of
his thinking the clarity was thinking
the fact that he started the company the
first sale Apple ever made was made
Barefoot like he walks into the bite
shop in Palo Alto or maybe Menlo Park
can't remember exactly whereas and he
makes apples for sale he doesn't have
shoes on he doesn't take baths like he
was completely like an inner scorecard
person there's this idea that I learned
from um reading uh this book called The
Snowball which is like a most well-known
biography of Warren Buffett and he talks
about he's like it's very hard to have a
happy life if you if you have an outer
score card as opposed to an underscore
card so what does that mean and he
Compares his growing up he had a real
bad relationship with his mom who was
all out of scorecard and yet his dad was
his Heroes all underscore card and what
underscore card means is like you're
doing what you want to do based on how
you feel about it right not his mom
would make decisions
should I do if I do this what will other
people think and so I also like the
writing of Tim Urban from wait but why
and he really helped crystallize this he
has this post called like the mammoth or
something like that but essentially it
just proves it's like the idea that
other people are thinking about you is a
myth people think about themselves and
he has these little stick drawings and
it's like in our mind it's like we're in
the center and all these people are
looking and pointing at us right and
then he goes this is what you think and
this is what happens like you're still
in the center but everybody's like
looking at their phone or they're
worried about other stuff right and so
to me it's a very very freeing and so he
said his dad made decisions based on how
he truly thought he didn't care what the
outside world thought which I think is
extremely
um like I I think like is extremely uh
important uh and I think it is a skill
to develop and his his
it destroyed like his relationship with
his mom the fact that she wanted to him
to make decisions based on like what
will other people think he's like he
didn't want to go to college which was
crazy at the time because his dad was a
congressman and everything and he's
already owning businesses healing like a
farm he had a bunch of stocks this is
like a young Warren Buffett he's like
he's like read 100 books on investing
he's like what what else am I going to
learn and so he they want to make him go
to uh uh go to school or whatever the
case is but what I like about Steve is
like Steve is all underscore card he's
like he had one of session I'm going to
make insanely great products that is a
term that he says insanely great
products he says that when he's like 20
says when he's 30. 40 says it right
before he dies that's how he describes
the iPad the way before he dies and so
what I respect about him is it's like
how the hell do you make great
world-class products in the 70s the 80s
the 90s 2000s and in 2010 right before
he died right
um but what's sad is I respect him for
what he did professionally but he says
in this uh this biography that he's
working on as he knows he's dying with
Walter Isaacson and at the end I
recommend even if you haven't even if
you don't want to read the whole book
because it's giant read the last page
last chapter or maybe last two chapters
where he describes his legacy so it's
like why he did what he did
and then he describes why he's spending
his some of his final days working on a
book and he says something that was
devastating to me he's just like I
wasn't around much and I want my kids to
know why I did this
and so like that's completely he's his
ruthlessness was not hey I'm gonna be
the richest person in the cemetery he
doesn't give two shits about that he's
like I'm gonna make world-class products
right and I'm gonna spend all of my time
and energy on my world-class products
and as a result he said where is that
time coming from
time is coming from taking care of his
health spending time with his wife and
his kids maybe spend time his wife that
part I don't know but like he definitely
missed out on you know some part of his
his kid's life you looked at the
Vanderbilts as well right especially
some of the some of the super early ones
I thought about them when it came to
ruthlessness
okay so this is fantastic so what I love
about what I think is inspiring about
the history of Entrepreneurship setting
it is like there was a Steve Jobs before
Steve Jobs right his name was Edwin land
he was the founder of Polaroid when you
when you hear Steve describe all of his
ideas like hey I'm going to build a
technology company at the intersection
of technology and liberal arts Steve
would use that he put a sign with those
the intersection on all of his Apple uh
product releases right that's not his
idea that he literally took that from
Edwin land he talked about this guy's my
hero Edmond Lane was 70 when when um
Steve Jobs met him Steve was in his 20s
he talked about how important Edward
when uh Was 1980 and as he's dying he's
still talking about the fact that Edwin
lamb was his hero now you brought up the
Vanderbilts everybody's like I get a lot
of questions like okay there's a Steve
Johnson for Steve Jobs there was a
Warren Buffett for Warren Buffett that's
really reassuring right there's Elon
Musk before an Elon Musk right
um
the the equivalent to a Cornelius
Vanderbilt when you get back in like the
robber baron era right and I'm about to
reread this book because it's so [ __ ]
crazy
there is no modern day entrepreneurial
equivalent of a Cornelius Vanderbilt
okay who I would compare him with is
Vladimir Putin okay why did I say that
because if you could have converted all
of Vanderbilt's assets at the time of
his death to cash he would have
controlled one out of every 20 American
dollars in circulation that is [ __ ]
crazy Bezos everywhere at the top of the
list is nowhere on a relative basis on
how much currency it actually was at the
time no one's [ __ ] close to that
right he had Sovereign level state level
wealth just like Putin controls it's
like oh it's like it's not my money okay
you're controlling it buddy but also
because like you know maybe uh Microsoft
Bill Gates and Steve Jobs might fight it
out uh Bill Gates and the founder of
Google they might Sue each other they
might argue they may say bad things
about each other right uh if you mess
with Cornelius Vanderbilt on a business
level he would try to [ __ ] kill you
that is not hyperbolic he literally did
there's this great book called tycoon's
War and it's about this guy I think his
name's William Walker and William Walker
was also a very social person like by
the time he's like 18 or 20 he graduated
uh he had his like master's degree law
degree and and uh it was a doctor like
you know one of these crazy Geniuses
winds up taking over a part of Mexico
when he was like in his early 20s like
they were like the people just lived
crazier lives back then anyways William
Walker also overthrew the government I
think it was Nicaragua and he becomes
president of Nicaragua right and uh at
the time
Vanderbilt had he was he was uh building
these new businesses where the Gold Rush
was going on and so a lot of people on
the East Coast wanted to find a way to
get to the West Coast and so you'd
either go to like the Panama Canal or
you go around like the the uh South
America and so Vanderbilt figured out a
way to cut through Central America
through like ships then donkeys and then
trains and all other crazy [ __ ] but it
saved like a ton of time so he was
making a lot of my goodness some of his
ships during this project just happen to
be in
the Waters of Nicaragua right so William
Walker is like hey uh I own this country
now those ships are technically mine and
so he made the DraStic machine mistake
of confiscating property
that came from Cornelius Vanderbilt
Cornelius Vanderbilt is like uh
uneducated like maybe sixth grade
education maybe not even that right he
came up on the docks in his first
business like they literally would solve
businesses with fists he would beat the
[ __ ] out of other people would compete
with this is a hard dude growing up in
an unbelievably tough environment now
he's one of the wealthiest people in the
world and you just picked a fight
there's a line in the book that says
William Walker wasn't afraid he's like
William Walker wasn't afraid of other
people uh he wasn't like other people
who was afraid of Cornelius Vanderbilt
when he should have been so Cornelius is
like okay you took my stuff that's my
stuff I'm not gonna sue you he has this
famous quote he's like I'm not going to
sue you the law is too too moves too
slow I'll just ruin you and so he goes
to the Secretary of State America he's
like hey we got to kill this guy I want
you to send troops down there they're
like no no we're gonna do that then he
goes to Britain same same thing like at
the highest levels of government which
is a funny story I can tell you about
Henry Flagler which is a John D
Rockefeller about how like this is great
line from will Durant and will and Ariel
Durant who've spent their entire life
studying human history and in this book
called lessons of History they say a
great line where it's like in every age
governments have been corrupt and men
have been dishonest it doesn't matter
what time periods always and the the
government corruption and the collusion
with a lot of Rich entrepreneurs is
content as well still happens to this
day
so anyways long story short he hires
private mercenaries uh some soldiers
from Americans so soldiers from uh uh
Britain to go after to get this guy they
wind up overflowing throwing his
temporary government taking him out to
the beach blindfolding him and killing
him
that's the Vanderbilts that's the the
level of the robber barons like there is
a violent aspect to it but there's also
a they just think way larger they were
not into competition all this was a comp
they like combination so let me give an
example you know the brand moat Moet
shund on the champagne well thank you
um
so they call the the owners of that
company they go to JP Morgan and they're
like there's a problem with somebody in
another competitor in the industry right
and so JP Morgan maybe say okay maybe I
need to buy the competitor because
they're they're decreasing my profits or
whatever
champagne can only be called champagne
if it's manufactured in that specific
region of France right I think that's
where it is JP Morgan's uh response is
just buy up the whole region
the level that these guys thought at is
just like you know now it's like I Gotta
Buy on my computer it's like no JP is
like I'm just gonna own everything every
single businesses in this region is now
mine it's like that kind of level of
grandiosity that you just don't really
see anymore
that's ruthless I suppose I wonder how
much um
business has been nerfed a little bit
it's certainly the Revenge of the Nerds
is something that people throw around a
lot at the moment but the business world
is optimized for people that have got
very very high IQs high
conscientiousness low agreeableness and
all that they do is obsess over one
thing for a very very long period of
time and that's where your competitive
Advantage comes from does this mean that
I absolutely love it's this sort of
broad guy maybe late 20s and he stood at
the front of a Bed Bath and Beyond and
he's like pretty big sort of built dude
and he's got this kind of crap shirt and
tie on that you would have if you worked
at a Bed Bath and Beyond and there's a
thought bubble coming out of his head
that says 5000 years ago I would have
been a proud warrior
okay I'm so I'm so glad you said this so
one of the craziest books I ever read
um was this book called hard drive uh
Bill Gates in the building of the
Microsoft Empire right and the reason
it's a fantastic book because it only it
covers the first 35 years of Bill Gates
life right up until the Microsoft IPL
and to me you know Bill Gates now is
like everybody thinks of him as like the
philanthropist you know he's like that's
like his big thing and he wants you to
you know cure Larry and spend all time
doing whatever weird [ __ ] that he does
right but again I just mentioned earlier
it's like I'm not interested in that
version of Bill Gates I want to know who
built his giant [ __ ] Empire and his
giant wealth and that dude was psychotic
complete psychopath didn't take one
single day off in his 20s uh literally
only thought about selling more software
Microsoft was the first software company
in the existence that sold a billion
dollars worth of software in a year now
that does that there's millions of
companies that are tons of companies
that do that but I made the point in the
podcast that I made about that where I
realized I also been a big fan of um uh
Dan Carlin who I think is like the
world's greatest podcaster his Wrath of
the con series I've listened to over and
over again I've read a bunch of books on
Genghis Khan
even though I pronounced it incorrectly
and I made the point like I've started
studying like I had just been finished
reading about uh Genghis and Bill Gates
and I'm like oh this is the same
personality type like if he was alive 8
000 years ago he'd be on Horseback
trying to chop your [ __ ] head off
because that's how you built wealth back
then it was Bill Gates has got Genghis
Khan energy no but like even like a
Napoleon like a diminutive like person
that that knows how to control other
people I called uh Bill Gates uh in that
podcast it's Genghis Khan in a Mr Rogers
costume he dresses like gang he dresses
like Mr Rogers you think he's like his
[ __ ] little weird nerd but he's
completely ruthless there's two stories
I want to tell you about Bill Gates that
are in uh uh in that book
where he's having a dispute when he's 21
years old right he is writing software
for this guy in New Mexico they're about
to move
um they're about to move uh which turns
into Microsoft into into Seattle he's
how he's like I want to break away from
this agreement that I have with this guy
where I'm only writing software for his
uh hobbyist computer he's like I'm gonna
I'm gonna write software for every
computer in the world and so Bill Gates
like I have to fight this guy if I'm
going to be able to do that and
obviously he needed to win that because
that he that was one step in his
eventual Monopoly and so this guy's much
older than Bill Gates he's like in his
mid-30s but he's realized like this guy
Bill Gates is [ __ ] Savage like this
is unbelievable and so his while this
this lawsuit is going through
his company the guy that Bill Gates is
fighting is sold to this company called
pertech and pertex like I'm not worried
I'm going to do this acquisition I'm not
worried about this lawsuit because I
looked at this guy it's like what's this
21 year old Shaggy [ __ ] kid gonna do
like we're gonna destroy him and the
guy's name is Ed Roberts and Ed Roberts
warned him he's like no no I've been
dealing with Bill Gates for a few years
he goes he said it was like uh FDR
saying he could handle Stalin it's just
like you have no idea what's about to
happen to you and sure enough Bill Gates
winds up running them over winning a
lawsuit and they were just completely
unprepared for his love of ruthlessness
and genius there's another example where
Bill Gates had encyclopedic knowledge
about every single other software
company in the computer industry he can
tell you who the CEO is What the revenue
was last year what their projects are
working on right and his whole thing is
what got him in trouble with the the US
Department of Justice because he's you
know some of the stuff will end up
getting emails and in documentation it's
like
I you didn't we didn't when he lost like
let's say Microsoft's competing with uh
for a hundred thousand dollar contract
and another company he's like if that
other company wins he would tell his
employees it's like you didn't lose me a
hundred thousand you lost me 200 000 and
he'd go [ __ ] ape [ __ ] because he's
like we lost a hundred thousand and they
gained a hundred thousand so that's a
200 000 loss so his whole thing is like
I want to destroy every single person in
my industry because I want a monopoly
and so there was this guy named Philippe
Khan I think is his name and you know he
he knew Bill Gates was gunning for him
but he didn't have any idea like to the
degree that they were actually like
targeting him because a lot of this
stuff is Secret so Philippe goes to a
computer conference right sees Bill
Gates in the corner sitting in a chair
by himself looking at something so
Philippe goes over because you know they
may be competing to be the enemies but
they still like talk to each other he
goes over and he discovers that Bill
Gates is sitting there staring at a
picture of him
that's how he was completely obsessed
he's like I look imagine how freaky
would that be if you had a competitor
you go over and he's looking at your
face just like thinking about how he
could [ __ ] destroy you so the reason
I say it's the same personality type is
because now wealth is can in many cases
like positive some right like uh you
create a new podcast that podcast brings
in Revenue you're not taking that money
from anybody else you're adding
something to the world back in gang is
Khan's time and really before the
invention of the market economy it's
like no it's like it was land it was
resources it was uh I'm obsessed with uh
this uh studying with the history of the
American West right uh like Empire of
the summer Moon and like on all these
books of like the commands and
everything else it's like why were the
Comanches so rich because the way they
did wealth was horses well where do they
get horses they went and went to where
you were killed you took your horses
your women and everything else like so
what we considered wealth was like
finite and you had to unfortunately like
and for most of human Industries like we
were just it was zero-sum game like
there could only be one winner so that
same personality that Vanderbilt type
that JP Morgan type Bezos he's clearly
an Empire Builder clearly it just so
happens he's born at a time where he can
do it without I shouldn't even say
taking away from other people because
he's destroyed a bunch of other
companies just like Rockefeller did but
you know what I mean like he can add
something to the world and not have to
kill you for the well yes without having
to kill a bunch of people perhaps or at
least directly kill a bunch of people
God does the uh
second order effects of whatever Bezos
has done with Amazon probably take
fairly deep you mentioned uh Jocko
earlier on yeah one of his big things is
dealing with discomfort and doing hard
things what have you learned from
Founders about the ability to deal with
discomfort
my there's a bunch of maxims so I um the
reason I think uh I'm So Into Charlie
Munger and the ball Rubicon is like they
I think you're very limited like people
can remember certain things like to
transfer uh lessons throughout human
history it's like a story we remember
things in stories right and remember
things in maximum so I try to break
things down to the aphorism and maximum
level the my favorite Maxim that I've
read in any of these [ __ ] books
throughout the history of
Entrepreneurship came from the founder
of Four Seasons this guy named Isador
sharp and he said Excellence is the
capacity to take pain
like in every single story there is none
you're not going to find and this is why
I think it's so important for people to
understand like the founders Journey
sounds a lot like the Hero Journey it's
like nothing's new Under the Sun right
and so
he wrote this fantastic book called uh
Four Seasons my business philosophy it's
his autobiography and he starts out he's
just working in construction with his
dad like it's an absolutely fantastic
book and he has this idea of like
building the the world's first
collection of five star only Hotel chain
right guy's still alive winds up he
actually this is gonna be funny he sold
his business to
some guy is one of like the kings of
Saudi Arabia and Bill Gates so tied us
to the Bill Gates Empire Building thing
like this guy you you don't have enough
money Bill like why are you buying the
Four Seasons Bill what the hell is wrong
with you these guys are Relentless uh
Elon just talked about the fact that he
he heard that
um
Bill Gates had like a 500 million dollar
short position on Tesla like a few years
ago it's like what is wrong with you
like this is what I say like he'd be on
because Genghis didn't stop he's just
like I'll just you know I'll just I'll
just keep going until I get to Europe
until like I hit the other c
um so anyways uh Izzy has a thing where
it's just like he he transitions from be
working construction and like building
maybe individual houses to like his
first business or whatever the case is
that book talks about like the amount of
emotional stress that you're going to be
under his wife has a great thing in the
book where she'd wake up at like three
in the morning and she'd find her
husband with like with arms behind his
head just looking up at the ceiling
trying to like deal with like [ __ ] I
have this big problem I don't where am I
gonna get the money how are we gonna do
this and so he realizes like it's
supposed to be difficult uh Jeff Bezos
has another great line he's like we're
trying to create something special
something we can tell our grandpa
something we can be proud of that we
could tell our grandchildren about those
things are not meant to be easy anything
that comes easy is almost worthless so
that's where I like resonate with Jaco's
my alarm clock dude like I wake up every
morning and a Jocko's like get to the
gym because you can buy his uh he's got
a spoken word uh album on iTunes called
uh psychological warfare and I was
playing it in the car with my wife the
other day because uh I work seven days a
week but the reason I do that is because
like I have a balance of spending time
my family taking care of my health and
working and I can't fit that Monday
through Friday or else I won't have like
there'll be some days where all I do is
work so I I find it better to spread out
over seven days and then you can
actually balance everything like the
Dork thing
um but I was playing a nice like Jaco
has a singer it's like this is an
everyday thing
like he has he's like there's no Monday
it's just he's just or there's no
Saturday he's just a hilarious person
um but the answer question there's no
book that I've ever read where it's like
oh this person had an idea to build a
business they started doing the business
it went great end of story it's like oh
I want to do this I take one step
forward three steps back oh damn that
hurt in fact have you seen this um
the greatest illustration of this comes
in like the first few minutes there's
this documentary on HBO you know who
Tony Hawk is the professional skater
yeah have you seen the documentary yet
no I think you'll like it especially
because I think you're gonna find a
parallel with the the journey you've
been on in building your podcast where
it shows Tony practicing trying to do
the the 920 that to invent that new uh
move in skating right and it starts out
and he goes up on the ramp and falls
down he's like oh gets back up then
tries again falls down gets back up then
he falls down again now he stays down a
little longer now he's like breathing
heavy he's like oh oh bringing things
like do I want to do this like gets back
up this goes on for like three or four
or five minutes to one point where like
he falls and Yelps in physical pain he's
like ah like like he broke a [ __ ] rib
or something right he's down for a long
time gets back up and I watched that and
by the time I saw that I had read like
you know 250 biographies I'm like oh
that's what's in the books it's you're
going to be experiencing pain most
people quit why do I have uh Shackleton
on my phone by endurance we conquer it
is supposed to be painful going into
that so the number one book
recommendation I have is James Dyson has
two autobiographies right he just wrote
a new another one that was published
that's not that's a fact I read that
book too it's it's great that's not the
book his first autobiography that came
out at the time Dyson only had it was
still only in the UK and he only had one
product which was his Cyclone vacuum now
he's built this Empire like one of the
most valuable private private hood
companies in the world right
but it the reason I recommend that book
is because it's 14 years of pain and
struggle and this weird guy that refuses
to quit he opens up the bag on the
Hoover Junior vacuum cleaner doesn't
understand why the suction doesn't work
when he's like
32 maybe and by the time he is holding
in his hand a vacuum cleaner he owns
completely that is up to his standards
that he can now start selling he's like
44 or 45. it's 14 years of struggling
and that entire book you can read in the
weekend first of all he's funny there's
a lot of good ideas on how to build a
business in there but the value to me is
like how many times he goes from his
Carriage House into after an entire day
of he built 5127 prototypes before he
got it right who the [ __ ] would do that
who would do 500 podcasts before they
get a monster break right it's the same
[ __ ] thing over and over again and so
but he's like listen I could say that
it's easy to say determination is
important persistence is important it's
another thing to go into your house
covered in suit crying your [ __ ] eyes
out as an adult man with a wife and two
kids of support with now a second
[ __ ] mortgage on my house that is
tied to my business and if I fail we
don't have a [ __ ] house
that is a different level of pain
tolerance
and what happens he sticks to it there's
been plenty of people that did that and
failed you have to be aware of
survivorship Fighters but what happens
now you fast forward right he has this
great thing um and now you fast forward
and he owns 100 of Dyson it makes
somewhere between
reportedly two to three to four billion
dollars of profit is it private private
so he was 100 of it [ __ ] off
and you know this because it's from the
UK where he had this invention called
the ball Barrow where he's like [ __ ]
this is way earlier in his career it's
also a story in the book where um
instead of like having a wheel it's a
ball and like she doesn't get stuck when
you're doing gardening and stuff and he
goes and does the photo shoot at some
giant you know you guys have these
Estates and mansions and uh I don't even
know what they're not in [ __ ]
Mansions they're Estates in in the UK or
whatever and he's like 20 years ago I
rented like I paid to take uh pictures
of this product that I made here and he
goes no I just bought this [ __ ] this is
mine now like but again that he like he
suffered through 14 years how many
people would absolutely quit and this is
like why it's important okay I know that
you've spoken to the guys that work with
Jack Butcher on his podcast I don't
think Jack was there and Jack's got that
super super famous graph which is you
are here right and it's the best talking
about that that famous uh illustration
that had been around for years and years
of these two guys digging and they're
both digging along together trying to
get toward diamonds and one of them
gives up just before he's about to hit
the diamonds and the other guy's still
enthusiastic
survivorship bias is an interesting
thing reason being that it is limited by
the people that didn't give up or it's
it's the it's always in reference to the
people that decided not to give up right
the survivors are the ones that do that
and for all of the people that uh the
Michael Jordan's of the world does that
story of him saying what do you want to
be when you grow up and he's 11 years
old or something and he says I want to
be an NBA star and the career advisor to
11 year old Kobe Kobe Kobe uh so if you
can't do this like this is maybe you
should pick something else maybe you
should be more realistic that's a one in
a million shot and he says I'm gonna be
that one in a million right
the people who do not make it to that
stage are the ones that can't dig into
consistency like you don't know if
consistency will get you there but you
can be guaranteed that if you are not
consistent you will not get there
yes
survivorship bias is an easy get out of
jail free card for a lot of people to
use when they see success that seems
improbable and they are concerned that
that sets a bad standard for people
moving forward
but you don't know
what the point is that almost everybody
else gets to at which everybody wants to
quit right there's this stat you
mentioned earlier on about podcasting
ninety percent of podcasts don't make it
past episode three and of the ten
percent that do 90 don't make it past
episode 20. so by making 21 podcast
episodes you're in the top percentile of
all podcasters ever in history that's
all it takes so what does that tell you
well it tells you that there is a degree
of discomfort or something there is some
sort of challenge that is faced by
almost everybody up by everybody that a
very very small number of people can get
over so is it survivorship bias to look
at shows that are successful and say
well you know that's highly improbable
you go well is it or is it just that
there is a particular hurdle which
tactically you need to get past and once
you do you're broken out into this
unbelievably vast open space with
relatively few competitors I think it's
a the quote that I learned from you
about your mediocrity is my opportunity
yeah
um this is the way I like I [ __ ] hate
when people bring that up because a lot
of people respond to like some post
um like if I if I say hey most of all my
social media channels are just like
repurposing highlights it's like I don't
have a lot of opinion my opinion is
irrelevant it's like hey this Michael
Jordan said this about this you might
find it valuable right uh the founder of
Dunkin Donuts said this you might find
it valuable like that's all it's all
educational content
um even if they never listen to the
podcast my goal with all my social media
channels is like oh you'll learn
something and hopefully you check out my
podcast if you don't that's cool I'm
fine with you just learning like these
little like me repurposing these 20 000
highlights I have and a lot of this
stuff is just like survivorship bias and
like I don't want to paint with a broad
brush because obviously it's a real
thing it's just like
to me that's like a loser mentality
right it's like I'm gonna figure this
out no matter what and I'll either
[ __ ] die like I'm going to do this or
I'm going to die trying like I have
found something I love so much and that
I will reverse engineer just like what
Dyson did dice is like okay it's like
you take these things in Little Steps
you're not a [ __ ] idiot dude like
there's more opportunity out there than
anybody could possibly imagine so dice
is like well why don't vacuum why do
bags get clogged this is [ __ ] weird
she's like well maybe I'll figure out
like and he was working on something
else he realized oh I can use a cyclone
he's like well how do I make Cyclone I
don't know how to make Cyclone so then
I'll figure out how to make Cyclone then
once I solve that okay now how do I sell
uh my vacuum cleaner do I license it he
went on licensing oh the licensing
doesn't work oh maybe I have to do it
myself do I need a partner okay attack
on a partner partnership didn't work
okay I'll do it myself it's like break
things down to smaller components and
then just figure it out for like me and
you it's very simple it's like all of
our time is broken down into we make the
podcast and then all of the other time
is like we just have to make people
aware of its existence and then the
podcast will convert them themselves
when people find Founders like what the
[ __ ] is going going on here why is this
[ __ ] guy with his giant head reading
all these biographies he's like then
they start listening then they listen to
one then he listens to two then they
listen to 40 and by the time they get to
30 40 50 episodes it is impossible for
them to not tell other people about it
and guess what the best market for a new
startup is a group of like-minded people
concentrated together that no one else
is serving well guess what what you're a
Founder I'm a founder who do you know
you know a ton of other [ __ ]
entrepreneurs and Founders and so if you
find someone's like hey this is valuable
for my work or I learned something from
Christmas podcast you don't shut up
about it just like if I see a great
movie or a great CD or a CD no I'm
showing my age a great track on Spotify
or whatever it's like I send it to our
funny Tick Tock it's natural to share
people so it's like for us it's very
simple it's like I'm gonna stay in the
game I'm going to try to be like you go
back I thought your early podcasts are
still great but I guarantee if you go
back to like episode 100 you're probably
like oh you're like I'm so much better
because I do the same thing I'll get
messages about like I listen to episode
50 last time like please don't please
please please stop but they don't you
know what I mean but that's also a good
thing Paul Graham talks about it's like
the great thing about painting is they
painters leave like a progression so you
can see the gradual refinement over time
and very few other domains uh show that
right but podcasting does go watch I was
listening to Joe Rogan my friend Eric
put me on a Joe Rogan back in like 2010
because he was into UFC he's like come
over my house and watch this this uh
podcast and I was like what the [ __ ] is
a podcast and then it'd be Joe sitting
on his couch his white couch with Brian
redband and there'd be like snow and
[ __ ] like it was on Ustream it wasn't I
don't even like we were not listening on
Apple podcasts I mean this is probably
2009 actually
um but my point is like then go see
compare Joe episode 2 or you know 50
with episode 2000. and this is the I'm
going to go back to um the survivorship
virus and I want to talk about something
else real quick that just that popped up
I just finished reading uh rereading
Peter thiel01 and he is his whole thing
is like he has a definitive world view
he's like you're not a [ __ ] lottery
ticket you have control and master over
the world you have to go out and like
you can have if you plan and drive to
things you can actually change the world
which is all entrepreneurs understand uh
Steve Jobs said the same thing he's like
once you realize that everything around
you was built by people no smarter than
you like you and you can make your own
things that other people interact with
you can literally change and poke the
world and something changed on the other
side of the uh other side you'll never
be the same but there's people what I
realize like there's so many people that
don't believe that they think life is
something that happens to them and so
what Peter Thiel says in that book he
quotes this Emerson quote shallow men
believe in luck strong men believe in
cause and effect yes you have to stay in
the game long enough to get lucky but
you know how you get Lucky by preparing
all the time by showing up every day for
[ __ ] years my podcast just like yours
has grown unbelievably like the rate of
growth in 2022 has been [ __ ] crazy
but what people didn't see is like me
sitting in a room buying my self for
four years every day before that that's
what I love what Kanye said on his and
I'm not talking about what the [ __ ] he
how he is now or anything else right but
on his first
on his first album he says he's like
lock yourself in a room for forever make
it five beats a day every day for three
Summers I deserve to do these numbers
that's it's so funny he's like I've been
making beats since I was 12. you didn't
know who the [ __ ] I was until I sold my
beat to Jay-Z when I was 24. you didn't
see the 12 years the time that you're
hanging out with friends you're going to
parties it's like I'm making beats and
I'm rapping on Beats there's a fantastic
if you want to talk about the founders
Journey the heroes Journey let's call it
the founders Journey uh the first two
episodes of Genius which is the Kanye
West documentary on Netflix skip the
third episode it's useless but those
first two he had the wherewithal to be
followed around when he was 20 21 22 23
by a [ __ ] camera crew as he's trying
to break into the industry that [ __ ]
that you see in this first and I played
on my computer over and over again
because I feel like I'm in that same
spot it's like I've been I was in my I
was in my this [ __ ] booth that you
see me in this soundproof booth reading
every day I was making five beats a day
for three Summers he's like now I just
broke in now see what I'm gonna do with
this I'm not I'm gonna put my foot on
the gas man take every opportunity I can
I'm going to keep working as much as I
possibly can and I because I believe in
cause and effect I'm going to do the
work necessary so I become lucky
and I don't give a [ __ ] about oh this
this podcaster you know did it for a
year or two and then quit that's
irrelevant to me because I'm not
quitting a family friend of mine
um my my brother-in-law's best friend
right they're like hey I know David's
into podcasting I started my own podcast
I'd love to be able to like pick his
brain about it and uh because he's a
family friend I was like yeah I'll talk
to you whatever he's like a nice guy so
he went up talking to him and he's
telling me about like he started this
podcast and he's like oh man I I did
some episodes and then I stopped and he
was talking about weird stuff where he'd
like have all his guests travel to like
a professional recording studio right
it's like you first of all you know any
of that like like just you need raps
reps Arnold Schwarzenegger's thing it's
like everything is reps right and then I
talked to him we were talking for a
while and then I found out wait a minute
this is like I don't know maybe 10 15
minutes of the conversation you can't
remember but I was like how many
episodes Have You Done he's like six
I was like call me back when you hit a
hundred click
the [ __ ] are we talking about I
literally told us like we have nothing
to talk about you've done six the the
odd the arrogance and he's not Aaron kid
the arrogance that you think you could
do something six times and be good at it
why hasn't the world delivered me what I
deserve
it's crazy and this is a nice smart kid
right I'm not like insulting but I was
like bro do [ __ ] hundred and then
what I think the reason the reason that
people have those points of view is
because they don't see behind the scenes
what's going on you know you look at the
Rogan with the several hundred million
dollar Spotify deal and all of the plays
and all of the accolades and all that
stuff and you think well yeah like I
know he's done for a long time but like
now surely there's a way to shortcut
that I can get to where he is or
somewhere close to that in a in less
time uh and there are people you know
there are people that have had uh
shortcuts to achieving that you know
Brendan show up is someone that gets
accused of being one of the people that
kind of got a q jump because of how much
time he got on a explosion he got from
Rogan you think well
maybe but is that really going to be
your growth strategy to hope to be
plucked out of obscurity and I'm not
convinced that that's going to be a
replicable way to do things so one thing
that a lot of people have probably got
in their minds is uh trying to
understand your Progressive
summarization uh technique you're
reading a lot of books your recall is
good
um high level what is the process that
you think is best for people to go
through if they want to retain the
important things from the books that
they read
so I think this actually ties together
um so Jerry Seinfeld has this great
interview with Harvard Business review
and they're like hey you know you kind
of micromanaged everything and uh you
know could you have like maybe instead
of doing a show for nine years you could
have done it for a lot longer you didn't
get burned out like maybe you would have
you should have hired McKenzie to help
you and he's like who's Mackenzie you're
like oh it's a consulting firm he's like
are they funny he's like no they're not
funny he's like then I don't need them
he's like the hard way is the right way
he's like I'm I go him and Larry wrote
every single word they picked every all
the actors they did everything right
he's like that's the only way I know how
to to work right and so my process is
very similar to that the way I related
to Joe Rogan is like if you think about
Joe Rogan's built uh an Empire with his
[ __ ] mouth with his mouth and
everything he does it looks easy people
like oh it's just like three hours of
you know shooting the [ __ ] with your
friends it's not easy as you as you know
right and if you think it was like
everything that he's interested in
like it's all these forms of practice
it's like he's obsessed with the UFC and
he's been a commentator for 20 years
that's his mouth he's had to be like
he's using he's he's learning how to to
break down what he's seeing and make it
interesting for The Listener uh and the
viewer right he's obsessed with comedy
he's been doing comedy for 30 [ __ ]
years same thing how many reps has that
guy put in on the microphone to make it
look easy when he goes in front of now
25 000 people right same thing as
podcast episode 1900 looks easy because
you didn't see the decade before so I
believe in the hard way so this is a our
mutual friend Eric Jorgensen we have a
lot of funny conversations because he
just cannot believe he's like so who who
edit your podcast I do why the hell is
like everything I do I'm really glad I'm
really glad that you brought up
Jorgensen because I was at the bachelor
party a couple of months ago and
obviously he's missed a leverage right
he's missed a scale he's Mr Mr Outsource
and I think that both me and you have
strategies when it comes to the way that
we do our project
that makes him feel nauseous frankly yes
and so his whole thing he's like David
you should only be fine listen Eric's
super smart the reason I like him is
because now he's a good writer but what
is rare is how articulate he is well you
probably interviewed a bunch of writers
like like you know like it's a he has he
he's able to be articulate and write
really well which I think he's like
we're just gonna see this guy's gonna
blow up I think his idea what he's doing
with all these versions of the almanac
and everything like I
that guy's gonna sell a [ __ ] ton of
books I wish I could invest in him if I
could invest in him I would yeah yeah
and so
he heard um I've told him this too where
okay so my process is crazy but there's
a reason for it so
um one of the things I love is that I
have an unfair Advantage Kanye said like
oh I have an unfair Advantage because
like I hear my Beats first right and my
unfair Advantage is like I read the
books first and all I do is like I'm
having one-sided conversations with
history you guys entrepreneurs and all
they do is tell me their best ideas and
then I can apply them to podcasting and
and put them through like my view of the
world and like my own unique spin on
things right and so one thing I learned
is like it gave me more confidence that
my way is the way that's right for me
it's Mozart was obviously very gifted
starts you know
creating music when he's like three
years old dies relatively young but his
he was like Psychopathic just like
Michael Jordan was in his form of
practice and he would practice more it's
funny he's like you think of a players
but like there's a difference between
like the top one percent and then like
the top zero one percent right and
Mozart's clearly at the top zero one
percent which is almost a different
world from the top one percent and so he
practiced way more than anybody else and
as a result he had physical attributes
that his competitors lacked and it's
like he had insane uh left hand strength
from playing certain instruments and
then what happens is there's these
Trends in music back then just like
trans uh now where there was this
instrument I think it's called like a
viola it's not a violin it's like
something called like a viola right
becomes extremely popular and what he
realized he had like a decade or two
decades of practice where his left hand
is so so much stronger and therefore
capable of making music with this
instrument that his competitors that did
not put in that time in practice lacked
and so by the time they're like hey I
want to jump on this trend
okay well you're 10 years behind and
you're never gonna you can't you
couldn't catch Mozart so my version is
that of that is
I read the books right
um I read physical books if I did Kindle
it'd be so much faster but I have a love
affair with like there's a romance to
physical books for me it's the first
books I read when I was you know five or
six years old so I sit down with a book
uh with a pen a ruler Post-it notes and
scissors it's like I'm [ __ ] doing
arts and crafts over here and I just I
read the book I start reading the page I
read in chronological order
um and then whatever I don't think about
it it's like all Instinct what jumps out
what like sometimes I'll highlight
almost everything on a page sometimes
I'll go [ __ ] 20 pages with nothing
it's what speaks to me and then I
highlight it and then I write down on a
Post-It note what comes to mind first it
could be like an interpretation of that
oh that made me think of this thing so
that's another thing I don't think of um
I know we have to we have to
um separate things into episodes but to
me it's like Founders is one giant 400
hour conversation on the history of
Entrepreneurship then I'm just going to
keep adding to like when I do an episode
on I just I'm doing an episode uh the
book I was reading this morning is
called uh what I learned before I sold
to Warren Buffett this guy built up this
giant uh diamond and jewelry business
and so with Warren Buffett in the 1990s
I that episode comes out it's not just
gonna be on that it's gonna be on how he
thinks it's relates to what Steve Jobs
said or this other person said here or
whatever the case is so I read
go through the book make my highlights
right then uh the night before I sit
down to record
I re-read all the highlights again not
the whole book but literally read my
highlights and the the notes so that's
the second time I've read them right
then I sit down in the morning me and
you were talking about before we start
recording uh I like to record my thing
my brain is so much Dumber in the
afternoon it's remarkable it's a
remarkable how dumb I am but in the
morning it feels when I feel sharpest I
sit down and go through and the way I
the the podcast is set up is like hey
what if you could meet up with your
friend who reads a lot and once a week
he just tells you the [ __ ] he learned
this week so I talk you've heard the
podcast like I talk directly to the
person there's no fourth wall it's like
I picture literally a [ __ ] friend
sitting in front of me and we just talk
just like that so now that's the third
time through then I edit all the
podcasts myself and there's not a lot of
editing it's like uh it's just like
maybe I'll get up to go to the bathroom
or like oh that part's boring in the
second part so I'll just cut that out
um but it's very straightforward because
it's like there's no production it's
just me one human talking another so
that's the fourth time I've heard the
the highlights then I take out this app
called read wise
and I take pictures on the IOS app of
you can take pictures of a page of a
book and it'll automatically read like
turn that text uh like do the text
recognition you have to like fix a few
things but I put all those highlights
into read wise and I type in my notes so
that's the fifth [ __ ] time
by the time I'm done with the book I've
read my highlights five times and then
my second half of the day which today I
haven't done uh because we're recording
the afternoon is I'll spend a few hours
just rereading like uh the IOS app on
read wise has this thing uh you pull it
up it's called highlights
uh highlights feed it looks like I'll
show it to the camera I don't know if
it's gonna pull up but it looks like a
Twitter feed but instead of tweets it's
I have my highlights from past books and
my notes on the book
um and then what I'll do is I'll use
that I got this idea for Michael
Bloomberg actually because he repurposed
the information that his the unique
information that his business collected
uh which was selling the subscriptions
of the financial data and then repurpose
that information into media form uh into
media content and his media Empire and
then that would then fuel subscriptions
to his you know his 25 000 seat whatever
thing so that's when people see tweets
uh or stuff on LinkedIn that's all
coming from a read wise app then I'll
film myself in this booth that you're
looking at right now reading those
highlights and put them on Tick Tock and
stuff like that and so it all funnels
back to and again it's a form of
practice so now by time I'll probably
record maybe Sunday morning maybe Monday
morning depends on how long it takes me
to read the book but by the time I sit
down
everything I'm about to say is informed
by the book I read but also all my
practice that I've done the previous six
or seven days
um and so my whole thing is like I'm
terrified of wasting anybody's time and
so that level of preparation one I think
is extremely rare especially in the
entrepreneurial domain I don't think I
don't I'm not don't I'm not saying this
is an arrogant thing it's like I release
a podcast every week I did 66 last last
year actually I don't think anybody else
is building a podcast exclusively
focused on Founders that does more
preparation than I do that releases as
fast as I do and so I'm obsessed with
just building the Warren buff thing
building that mode the longer this goes
on the more difficult I am going to be
to compete in the future because I think
of these it's not it's an obsession
that happens to be a podcast or a
session disguises a podcast that happens
to be a business and so being smart is
like how do I again you you know this
because you have 500 [ __ ] 60 [ __ ]
episodes it's like it's gonna be very
hard for you to replicate what you've
been building up and all this [ __ ] that
you're learning that then informs the
conversations you have in the future
with somebody saying hey I'm gonna you
know I like what Chris does I'm gonna
jump in and try to compete head with
them good [ __ ] luck buddy
dude I'm really impressed with what
you're doing I think it's great uh I
think that teaching people through
stories especially stories from history
uh some of my favorite modes of learning
Ryan holiday Robert Greene you know
these guys have made absolute monster
careers out of being
um
historians masquerading as philosophers
uh and uh it's a very cool way to
approach it uh so let's wind this one up
before you go three books that you most
often gift to people
well okay so
the most often that a gift to people
would be uh
uh against the odds and autobiography by
James Dyson it is was published you know
20 something years ago it is now hard to
find it's out of print it is somewhat
expensive I have a friend that just
bought it he paid 100 it's [ __ ] worth
a hundred dollars it's worth way more
than that those are hard to find I give
uh Eric jorgensen's the almanac and of
all a lot away a lot
um there's a fantastic book called The
River of Doubt which is a biography on
Teddy Roosevelt but it it focuses on him
his life after he lost the last
presidential election
uh Teddy's one of my personal Heroes as
well his approach to life um in fact I'm
about to do uh I've just bought Edmund
Morris's three-part biography of Teddy
Roosevelt it's 3 000 pages I have to
read on Teddy which I'm looking forward
to but anyways this River of doubt it's
X it's about the capacity take pain
endurance treating life like the
adventure it is he goes it's like hey I
need to like any time he went to
something rough in life he looked for
his his motto is get action and he's
like I need to the physical emotional
pain I have is only alleviated through
physical action right and so he's like
I'm gonna go down to the Amazon and I'm
going to map out a tributary of this
river that no one's ever completed and
he almost dies it's just the writing is
absolutely fantastic two other books and
a yes or three but um one of the best
books if you can find it I don't give
this as a gift a lot because it's hard
to find Estee Lauder wrote one of the
best autobiographies that you can ever
find a complete obsessive her I'm using
her Playbook a lot in the way I'm
building Founders and like she's just
obsessed over customers did things that
did not scale she writes the book
she dies the PO the company is still a
private family company and now it's you
know doing like 18 billion dollars of
Revenue it's called a success story by
Estee Lauder really hard to find but you
can read it in a weekend full of just
useful information
um and then I I would add uh one other
book you have to read a biography of
Steve Jobs in my opinion I've read
everyone that's available the best one
if you only had to read one it's called
becoming Steve Jobs the evolution of a
reckless upstart to a Visionary leader I
think is the turn the title and that's a
shorter version you get a full sense of
who he is in like 300 Pages dude I love
it why should people go if they want to
check out the stuff you do founders
podcast by David Center and any podcast
player that's basically it I put my
entire all of my life energy into that
one vehicle and I'd be thrilled if you
guys try to test it out dude thank you
oh thank you I'm super happy to that I
got a chance to meet you and to be
connected so I really appreciate that
yeah no problem what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]